we've long told you about activist
judges undermining Trump's immigration
policies but this next story is
outrageous a district court judge in
Massachusetts is accused of helping an
illegal immigrant sneak out a back door
to avoid being deported here's the back
story Jose Medina Perez of the Dominican
Republic was in court on drug charges
and also faced a fugitive warrant for
drunk driving in a new audio recording
obtained by the Boston Globe
his defense attorney is heard at the
bench with the prosecutor and judge
Shelly Joseph
they raised doubt about whether Medina
Perez had been correctly identified by
ice and whether he should be set free
listen I don't think it Sam
[Music]
[Music]
now minutes after that recording
witnesses say the illegal was escorted
out of back door and then released from
custody he then scaled the fence and
escaped
we should note he has not been caught
joining me now Leo Terrell a civil
rights attorney and Brian Kelly a former
federal prosecutor in Massachusetts
Brian I want to start with you how are
unique is how unique is it to have a
federal investigation into a sitting
state court judge on an issue such as
this well it's not common at all Laura
in you know it's a bizarre set of facts
right the defendant is arrested on drug
charges
he's been deported twice before and then
because for whatever reason the judge
turns off the tape recorder contrary to
court rules we don't really know what
what she says next next thing you know
he's running out the back door onto the
streets of Boston so I think even by
Massachusetts standards this is a little
bit too much judicial activism and it's
led to according to the Boston Globe a
federal investigation a grand jury
investigation and that in and of itself
is quite unusual well he has since been
caught I want to make sure I get that
right so he's since been caught but the
underlying facts of this are really
disturbing governor Charlie Baker spoke
out about this Leo I want your reaction
let's watch the facts of this case as
presented by the media indicate
a willful attempt to obstruct the work
of a federal law enforcement official
and that's an inappropriate role for a
judge now I guess judge Shelley has not
been in on the bench very long but
nevertheless Leo would you say judge
Joseph would you say that this is
warranted is this extrajudicial conduct
I mean when you look up activist judge
it says really activist judge it's not
just a ruling this is go well Laura hi
thanks for having me and first of all
we're going after the judge what about
the prosecutor or the defense attorney
and the officer who allowed him out did
you escape I find this really odd
because as the governor said based on
the facts from the public where's the
investigation of the district attorney
in the prosecutor wasn't there a
conspiracy when they all got before the
judge and said all these things so I
think my colleague who's on the show is
ignoring the prosecutor who represents
the state of Massachusetts and the
defense attorney why sing about the
judge why I'm confused what are the
points Brian well I think people I think
people expect a judge to uphold the law
interpret the law but not subvert the
law so I think the focus is on the judge
right now because it's such a bizarre
set of facts and so that's why I think
the judge is under investigation we
don't know what the grand jury will find
apparently according to the Boston Globe
they are investigating they're hearing
different witnesses so who knows where
it will lead but this is not what are
you on national TV
are you a national TV saying that it was
just a judge and nobody else and you
know as well as I do being a federal
prosecutor that there's got to be some
evidence where the judge actively
instructed someone and you're just
speculating right mastication we're
speculating look there's there's
evidence on the record where she says
ice is going to get him and then in
violation in Vice violation of the court
rules
she turns off the tape recorder and she
doesn't turn off the tape recorder
because she said she's obeying the court
rules she knows she's doing something it
seems
that's not appropriate and next thing
you know defendant in the illegal alien
is running out the back door onto the
streets of Boston he was gonna get out
of literally getting a get out of
deportation free card okay that's what
what about what about why would you get
the prosecutor on the Laura Ingraham
show the prosecutor and the defense
attorneys say what did it just leo I
love that if you want to be my Booker
Andrew will not be happy about that
okay let me just say that but we can and
will always take booking help Bob and I
love that but here's the problem is in
Massachusetts we have at least some of
the counties are sanctuary counties
Boston itself is a sanctuary City
correct so this is this is kind of in
the DNA now Boston that you don't want
to release people out the front door the
courtroom because ice is going to on
occasion we hope more than on occasion
be there to arrest them once they're
released and they know that that's why
they go out the back door
sneak out I guess we now have sanctuary
courtrooms good well let me say this
based on that well well if you are
having a sanctuary city you have just
stated that every official who endorsed
a state-sponsored sanctuary City should
be arrested for failing to cooperate
with ice that's what you're basically
saying might go a little far but not
warm you're getting warm leo
all right great to meet you guys thanks
so much